(beatboxing)
♪ New Father Chronicles. ♪
- [La Guardia] I filmed the beginnings
of this journey of fatherhood,
along that way, it turned into a career.
So something that was a
passion allowed me to take care
of my family doing
something I really loved.
I just want you to stop
eating random things
you find on the ground.
- Gimme a reason!
- My name is La Guardia Cross,
and I tell the funniest parts
of being a father, with my
two daughters, on YouTube.
Mainly by making fun of myself.
Fatherhood came unexpectedly to me,
when my wife called me
in and let me know that,
whoopsie daisy, we're
about to have a daughter.
The beginning of me sharing my experience
as a father online was day two
of me being in the hospital.
I described my first few
days of being a father,
and so when I did that,
the response was like,
"That's hilarious, you gotta
share more about that."
And that was the beginning
of New Father Chronicles.
Nayely's a year and a half.
- Daddy.
- Nayely is a determined baby.
Amalah is 3.
She really, really loves attention.
- Close, close, close.
Far away.
- So, whatever happens,
I usually will take that
and craft it into a story
based upon the funniest parts of it.
The very first video that
solidified New Father Chronicles
was 'Interview with a toddler."
So you've been alive for 14 months now,
you're walkin, you're
talkin, you're clappin,
(hands clapping)
you're dancin, (baby laughs)
you don't have to do an example.
It allowed an open door
to be able to create
a whole new kind of family entertainment,
showcasing a very silly,
but positive black family.
As the newest and youngest
member of the family
from your perspective, who
do you think is in charge?
- (baby gibberish)
- (laughs) Oh, you're
so cute and so confused.
(bright piano music)
The thing that kind of
really hit me to let me know
how important the work I was doing was,
when I spoke to people
about it, they were like,
"Let us just tell you how
important this work is,
"and what it means to
us, and to our families,
"and in the community overall."
And it just was a motivating factor.
There are not a whole lot
of black fathers on YouTube
doing what I'm doing.
It is a blessing to me
to be in this space,
to be able to create
the content I'm making.
So it's been incredible to connect
with other fathers online.
I'm a cool Dad; I don't
care what my girls say.
(happy classical music)